shawn mendes and camila cabello have
called it quits they both announced the
news on their instagram stories
wednesday night writing quote hey guys
we've decided to end our romantic
relationship but our love for one
another as humans is stronger than ever
adding quote we started our relationship
as best friends and will continue to be
best friends we so appreciate your
support from the beginning and moving
forward camila and sean he's the best
and i think we're really supportive of
each other news of the breakup comes as
a surprise for the couple who was just
together celebrating the day of the dead
singing and dancing and matching
folklorico outfits
sean and camila started dating in july
of 2019 and moved in together during the
covet 19 pandemic i really think when
you know you know and um she's been one
of my best friends since i was like 15
years old so
i don't know at the same time i know
we're really young so i don't want to
jump like insanely fast but
i think when you find your person you
feel and you know that you found your
person the two recently celebrated their
two-year anniversary and were all smiles
as they hit the red carpets at this
year's met gala and at the premiere of
camila's movie cinderella i think we're
both
extremely mushy people we're both super
sensitive which is creates a lot of
sensitive sensitivity in our
relationship but we are songwriters so
we're constantly searching for the
sensitive topics in life and um
i don't know i'm pretty mushy i i when i
don't know what she would and how she
went into that i feel like she would
maybe say i'm much more mushy in 2019
camila opened up to e.t about how their
love inspired her songwriting
i just feel like i really painted the
details of you know like when you're
first dating someone that you've been
friends with for a really long time and
it just feels like
oh my god like we're kissing now and
it's you know i i think i just really
captured what that moment
felt like for me